welcome back
our next guest is a very good friend of
mine and i love it when she comes to
visit this is like bring your friend to
work day
i love her you know her as the co-anchor
of one of the best and most important
shows on television the today show
and uh luckily she is here right now
with us today please welcome savannah
guthrie
[Applause]
not i know we literally were like oh my
god we both were scared
i actually did think of you though i was
like this is a good drew skirt this is
actually a dress and i just put this
thing over it
really yeah yeah that's
that yeah um okay we just spent your
50th birthday party together yes we did
it was so fun
you were so sweet to come it's the first
and only party i've been to well it was
kind of crazy we decided to do it i mean
i'm turning 50. i felt like
i'm not going to hide out or be all
mopey about it i'm actually super happy
i love middle age let's hear it from
middle age
and so we had a party and it was a new
year's eve party and you were so sweet
to come and we had fun and we danced and
it was like it was just it was just a
really fun thing to do i thought you
know what this is a reason to get
together and now we finally have
something to do you know so fun thank
you like for having me and it was just
it was the most fun and it i i just
needed
i needed that in my life it was such a
gift to everybody to do something safe
and normal and communal and celebratory
and i think it's what actually sent me
into 2022 in the best mood ever i have
been feeling so good
it really well you know what i think
we're all
i don't like new year's eve but i love a
new year don't you i mean i just like to
start something new start fresh it's
just full of possibilities did you not
like new year's eve ever though for the
idea of kissing a stranger mistletoe
or
stranger new year's kiss can i tell you
something that i didn't need new year's
eve to kiss strangers when i was yeah
like
i was yeah i did not need an occasion
to like you know make out i wasn't like
a i don't want to give you a makeup band
i was on make out bandits me too i was
like but it was like seventh grade like
don't even try to like
put your hand up my shirt i was like i
was like good girl but i did like to
make out face i i used to like walk into
places and just be like you
right now
i was so daring i know me too i kind of
miss those games i know you can
you're drop dead gorgeous and single you
can make out all the time i'll be your
wing woman i need you to be my women but
you know what our problem is we like to
meet literally at 3 30 or 4 p.m in the
afternoon we have a date this weekend
and i'm like can you are you sure you
want to wait till four i can do earlier
i go up about four she goes sure and if
you want to come earlier we can do it
earlier okay listen um i wore all my
earrings in honor of you today it's
funny i was just admiring all this look
at the bling oh so i did it i snatched
that right off of you what you can have
it all it's beautiful um maria that's i
love marietech i have many maria taps
okay how many do you have well friends
i can't believe it i have four in each
one so none of them are the same they're
all different um
my friend our friend carson daly is like
savannah you and my wife are trying to
turn back the hands of time with these
this ear piercing thing i do it's given
me like adornment it feels a little
sexy it feels more in touch with who i
used to be
my my 16 year old self was very
spiritual
she was very cool and she's not to be
dismissed now because we're working mom
no and i like all your rings too see
we're all like definitely on the same
page yeah what is it why are we doing
this what's happening to us i'm like
this is my rebellion you know it's like
i just want to be like a secret punk
rocker or goth or something what i don't
have and you do and i'm admiring is a
tattoo would you ever get a tattoo
i would and i kind of want to right now
like my mother's just rolling her eyes
but one two three go you're at a tattoo
parlor and this is it you're getting one
what is it
okay i would like something
i'm copying someone actually that i work
with she had her her mom
her mom's handwriting lightly done like
yours is and she her mom wrote love you
more because that's what they say to
each other so i would actually like
something cool like that with my mom my
mom turns 80 today by the way oh my god
so
happy birthday yes i feel like we need
to leave the studio and go get this
tattoo in honor of her 80th birthday i
would get a tattoo with you yes any time
but i want to get another one yeah i
want to get one right here okay so why
don't we go and i know exactly what i
want what are you going to say i want to
put 222 um in the digital clock um font
yes because my birthday is february 22nd
and this year it's going to be 2 22 22.
oh i love that so i'm doing it this year
okay so let's go let's go
done
we're doing it
[Music]